[Music]
coffee in the morning is so good hey
guys I'm Daniel welcome to my channel if
you're new here subscribe click the
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos now many of my
subscribers many of you guys asked me
hey Daniel what is the best facial wash
for oily skin so I'm not gonna waste any
time let's get right into the video and
I'll tell you alright so how do you know
what face wash to use for your oily skin
because there's a lot of skin care
products out there right a lot of facial
washes that claim to help you with your
oily skin but then they have ingredients
in them that actually just aggravate
your skin makes it worse and it just
triggers more oil which which is not
what you want right so you need a gentle
water-soluble cleanser one that is free
from any kind of fragrances free from
any kind of drying ingredients maybe
I'll make a video about the causes and
solutions of oily skin then you can
understand it a little bit better but
this is a video request only about the
best face wash for all these skins so
let's start with the first one
jet-black glycolic facial cleanser now
this is a clay based cleanser that
washes away dead skin cells and pore
clogging oil it really is great in
absorbing the oil without drying out
your skin as always i'll add it for any
video description with all the other
products as well that i'm gonna talk
about in this video so you can go and
check it out and do your own research as
well now let's move on to the next one
next up a set of Phil's daily facial
cleanser now this is a classic it's been
around for ages and it is still very
hard to beat you if you're looking for a
basic facial cleanser that really works
this is the one that you can try lab
series oil control face wash now labs
here is is actually a brand that I
haven't really talked about but they are
really good they have some good products
like this face control oil wash which is
really well yeah it's good enough to
make the top 5 plannig oil control of
facial wash now Clinique is a very good
brand they've got very good skin care
products and their oil control facial
wash is no different
I mean I've used their products a lot
especially in my early twenties for a
few years and it really is good but a
facial wash on its own is not gonna be
as good as the whole skin gear set the
basic skin care set the good face was on
its own is a very good start to treat
your oily skin right but you will also
benefit from a good exfoliant why
because a good exfoliant will remove
those dead skin cells and also the
buildup on the oil that you don't want
and then lastly a good moisturizer as
the finishing kind of effect to hydrate
prepare and control the kind of shine
effect that you don't really want you
just want that nice matte look all right
the last one my most favorite one a lot
of you guys who subscribe to my channel
who seen some of my skincare videos
probably know this already but my most
favorite fish was is
the face was frumpy seek for men why
because it's not just good for people
with oily skin but for all skin types
it's a kind of gel a liquid and so when
you wash your face it cleanses you from
dirt and oil and it also leaves your
skin nice and soft at the same time so
it's really good just some last advice
try to stay away from any kind of skin
aggravating scrubs or cleansing brushes
with stiff bristles we will just make
you know just aggravate your skin and
make things a lot worse just use a
gentle nice soft washcloth that'll do
the trick all right guys remember I've
added all this products for you in a
video description so you can go and
check it out your own research if you
liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video Cheers
[Music]